to me
[Music]
being a refugee is also being an
alchemist these are individuals who lost
everything and from nothing
are able to manifest so much
and i think
surviving displacement
should be celebrated
[Music]
my name is meimuna hussain kitan i'm the
founder and executive director of the
tia foundation right now we're at my
restaurant flavors from afar in little
ethiopia
little ethiopia is one of the first
african enclaves in california it's a
strip here in los angeles to me
establishing a restaurant here in little
ethiopia made sense with my journey
because my parents are refugees from
ethiopia they had fled in the 70s and i
was born in a refugee camp in somalia in
1980 it just felt like a full circle
to even have the opportunity to find
this space and to establish a restaurant
on the street
i employ
former asylum seekers and refugees that
were displaced and the reason why that's
personal to me is because i know
firsthand that you want to preserve your
dishes from back home it helps you feel
connected to your homeland
the main mission of flavors from afar is
to help immigrant chefs especially women
and to provide a platform to celebrate
their cuisines
oh i love it i i it's different you can
eat different food you can meet
different people
i feel maimuna has given refugees the
opportunity to experience themselves
with the community just an opportunity
to
be who i am represent my palestinian
cuisine as a refugee with people from
all over the world and this is just a
gift
it's nice to give everyone a platform to
be celebrated to be seen you know our
chefs receive five percent of the gross
sales throughout the month we provide
them headshots we curate their menu we
provide marketing for them so there's a
whole package ready to go so by the end
of the month if they want to continue to
pursue maybe a catering business or
pursue working in another restaurant
they have a portfolio that's been
created
what i hope for for the communities and
the chefs that we work with is that
becoming an entrepreneur is possible
and that they do have talents and gifts
to contribute
and a lot of people
have a desire and need to try their
dishes
for so long i felt invisible
and
there wasn't
spaces that were ever appropriate for me
to talk about my family's refugee
journey
so it's just something that was kind of
in the backdrop but you don't talk about
the experience you don't talk about the
ptsd at home you don't talk about
the struggles and the obstacles
to finally have the chance to talk about
these difficult topics and celebrate
people
after
displacement
and really humanizing their stories
celebrating their cuisines
that really means a lot so
while i do this for others i too get the
chance to
feel seen and celebrated
refugees are very very important part of
our society they have skills they have
feelings they have experiences they have
history they have families
flavors from afar is one of the
structures or one of the platforms that
showed that that proved that and showed
refugees to the world in a more powerful
and more beautiful image but there are
so many layers to that refugee and this
has to be seen
i think people misunderstood like they
come from a different country they're
different
but we're not different we're all the
same after 11 years of ups and downs i
would love to just have a sabbatical to
travel back home to ethiopia to see my
relatives to see my grandma who's in
nairobi
hey everyone today i'm about to give a
huge surprise to meimuna founder and
owner of flavors from afar a restaurant
that employs refugee chefs from all
around the world
[Music]
so what's the tia foundation
tia means my love in my family's
language we're refugees from ethiopia
and
our non-profit
was established to help
newly arrived
refugees and immigrants that are
starting over here in the u.s
and how did the restaurant branch from
the non-profit the restaurant was
inspired by survival
i hit a point where i had to think about
sustainability the best way to do that
is by using the resources
that
are around you already we're already
surrounded by talented people who have
food from all over the world
so i launched as a catering service
originally it just you know
took off from there i want to thank you
so much for sharing your story and your
experience with us
and since you do so much for your
community we actually want to give you
something
zell is going to send you 3 000
to continue the amazing work you're
doing
and thanks to
it will be in your bank account in
minutes
so we just we want to thank you so much
come here
you're incredible
[Music]